there's been more fighting overnight in
Sudan where rival forces remain locked
in a power struggle despite
international calls for a ceasefire
[Applause]
the UN says that more than 180 people
have been killed in more than three days
of fighting between the Sudanese Army
and the country's largest paramilitary
force a further 1 800 have been injured
in the violence in the capital Khartoum
and other cities the un's envoy to Sudan
says the warring parties are not open to
peace talks hospitals home and homes and
power stations have been shelled now to
Serious hibber Morgan is in Khartoum
hartum airport and the areas around it
were Battlegrounds on the third day of
fighting between Sudan's Army and the
biggest and most powerful paramilitary
force
exclusions airstrikes and gunshots are
heard across the capital as both sides
claim they're making advances in
strategic areas but details on the
ground are unclear
footage released by the Sudanese
military shows a number of Rapid support
forces troops surrendering their weapons
and equipment in Khartoum the Army says
it's resumed control of State TV and
will use it to update the public It also
says it's retake in Metairie airport in
the north but that conflicts with claims
by the rsf which says its men still
control the facility
airport is still under the control of
the Sudanese Army right now we are
inside meru airport as you can see there
is a plane behind us and we are
stationed here until the victory the rsf
also says an army-led Battalion handed
over its vehicles in the Eastern Nile
parts of hartum State Sudan has been
brought to a standstill after attempts
to open a humanitarian Corridor field
fighting destroyed khartoum's main water
station raising fears of widespread food
and water shortages only one still water
bottle left
this is a one and only one and
everything is MD Now the water bottle
section looks so empty
all the water whole milk everything is
empty here on the refrigerator
thousand wow see everything is colors
nothing left foot stroke is not
available
injured and many to evacuate doctors say
they're running out of medical supplies
Medics say the reported numbers of dead
or injured do not reflect the reality on
the ground that's because fighting on
the streets makes it hard to reach
hospitals or count the dead civilians
remain trapped in their homes waiting
for the fighting to end so they can feel
safe again a power struggle between Army
Chief General Abdel fattah al-burhan and
his Deputy Muhammad hamdan commander of
the rsf triggered the outbreak of
fighting on Saturday with neither side
willing to back down
while extracts continue and the worrying
sides show no desire for talks it's the
people of Sudan that are paying the
heaviest price Hiba Morgan Al Jazeera
Horton
Ahmed Abbas Abu sham is the vice
president of the Sudan doctors union he
says the situation in Khartoum is dire
in the last couple of days
the major teaching hospitals
been founded on going back with this
heavy artillery and there have been
revealed damaged to the extent that
there are uncomfortable on operational
at the moment and there are most people
say that anymore
besides that the remaining Hospital are
also dormant and malfunctioning
because the electricity power are being
cut and the water supply has been
prepared so virtually all the medical
institutions in cartoon are
non-functioning at the moment so because
the doctors and the other medical
personnel could not reach the hospitals
or other Medical Center
because Indonesia Bridge on the River
Nile has been blocked by the recently as
well so the injured the person or either
locally with primitive measures or
arthritis Aid measures and some of them
left to die
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
has spoken directly to the leaders of
Sudan's rival forces calling for an end
to hostilities and urging them to ensure
that the safety of civilians and Aid
workers earlier the U.N Secretary
General Antonio Gutierrez condemned the
violence warning of a humanitarian
catastrophe a diplomatic editor James
Bayes reports
the U.N security Council is calling for
an urgent ceasefire although behind the
scenes there are certainly divisions
about how to proceed the council was
briefed by the un's top official in
cartoon volkapathas after that close
meeting a visibly tired Mr pethers spoke
to reporters at un headquarters by
videolink there's the two sides who are
fighting are not giving us the
impression that they want mediation for
a peace between them right away
rather they are calling on the other
side to to when
um uh the other side to give up but to
surrender of the other side to be
disbanded so that that doesn't sound
very much like a preparedness to
give into
um and our mediation efforts to succeed
on short notice Mr pether says it's too
dangerous for him to travel around
Khartoum but is in touch by phone with
the two rival generals who he believes
are both still in the city I will be
just saying it in public in New York the
UN Secretary General has also had talks
with each of the two men as well as with
regional leaders
the situation has already led to
horrendous loss of life including many
civilians
any further escalation could be
devastating for the country and the
region
I urge all those with influence over the
situation to use it in the cause of
peace to support efforts to end the
violence restore order and return to the
passive transition
humanitarian situation in Sudan was
already precarious and is now
catastrophic the African unions call for
an immediate ceasefire by the two
parties the three African countries on
the security Council have called for
Sudan's airspace to be reopened so that
mediators can travel there the igad
group of regional countries wants to
dispatch a delegation the peace and
Security Council of the African Union
are planning a field Mission and the
chairperson of the African Union
musafaki wants to go to Cartoon to
mediate but for now Sudan's borders are
closed and in recent days the airport
has been a battlefield for now the um
believes its best hope is to expand its
humanitarian pauses and eventually turn
them into a durable ceasefire James
Bay's Al Jazeera of the United Nations
Egypt and South Sudan say they've been
in regular contact with the warring
sides and are prepared to help with
peace efforts
if I had a message to deliver and I have
said this to president salvakir of South
Sudan we are both ready to play a
mediation role between our brothers in
Sudan in order to reach a truce this is
still going on and we have endless calls
between the Sudanese armed forces and
the rapid support forces we are in
constant contact with them to encourage
them on a ceasefire an end to the
Bloodshed of the Sudanese people and
reaching negotiations that leads to
restoring stability once again